and you got over Tessa
the Volusia he has never been able of Oz
moralistic about its vagueness terenia
be leaky radomir Wolkoff hmm God decides
Gosai user yes there he is laughing you
wish to do it the noms apply telling if
like eating yet the poem yet with the
Burroughs
Wladimir we spoke a lot today about your
work with the soviet lune program in the
60s you were an integral member I guess
what I don't understand is why stop
there you were a man at the height of
his career young ambitious passionate
even today I can still see that passion
in you and yet when the moon program
closed in 74 afterwards there's no
record of any of your work within the
space program why is that my uncle says
that it was a great honor to be part of
such a historic program but that he
wanted to focus on his personal life of
course is that it my uncle isn't well
I'd like to take him home just one more
thing
operation average I know about the
station I know they recruited you I know
you were the flight director with ground
control during the incident Roger
Yvonne's on Norwich uh-huh nikka she's
King stop it please
and you are real stop it it's all there
right near where the missing piece to
the puzzle since ever use it look I know
this dish no military Marcus I know the
truth about everything Mia knows else to
see it además the proof is buried so
deep you never find it just like all of
them
[ __ ]
I use night